[Applause]
and
finally new rule as bad as last week was
worst school trip ever
let's not confuse 5 5000 people with 74
million
excuse me yes even even supporting the
insurrection
in spirit is well deplorable
but there's a difference between holding
illiberal beliefs and acting violently
on them
at least that's what they always told me
about islamic terrorism
i keep wrestling on this show with the
hard question of how do americans
all of us learn to share a country with
[ __ ] you can't stand
i've preached and still do that you can
hate trump
but not all the people who like him and
as counter-intuitive as it may seem you
can like something run by [ __ ]
without being one yourself just ask
chick-fil-a
there's been so much liberal happy talk
this week jerking each other off about
how oh this is the end of the
republicans now
yeah just like watergate was the end of
the republicans
and bush after katrina was and now it's
trump
please does anyone think that no matter
who's running in 2024 on election day
it won't be extremely close i'll bet
anyone out there a quadrillion zillion
dollars it will be
because 74 million trump voters are not
self-deporting
and neither are we one of the casualties
in this attack on the capitol this month
was ashley babbitt she was a
trump-loving small business owner she
had a pool cleaning company right down
the road here in san diego
she was an air force vet who served in
iraq and afghanistan
and she lost her life trying to prevent
biden from becoming president even
though she had voted for the obama biden
ticket
not that long ago but somehow
she came to believe that if joe became
president horses
full of greeks would rape our women and
georgia would go communist
she is the tragedy of the modern
republican voter personified
pissed off at the greed and corruption
that yes
has squeezed the middle class hard but
always coming up with the wrong answer
to
who is doing most of this squeezing
she was in financial trouble because in
order to keep her business afloat
she resorted to a short-term loan with
an interest rate of 169 percent
that's right she was being charged 169
interest and went to washington so she
could chant
stop the steal
she died for a second trump term even
though that would have solved exactly
none of her problems
the same mistake made by all of her
friends in the waffle house brigade
guys you were storming the wrong
building
the uh feet up shouldn't have been on
pelosi's desk they should have been on
trump's tanning bed
you thought trump was going to be your
bull in the china shop
yeah he was but you were the china
so should ashley babbitt have applied
better logic in seeing that her real
problem in life wasn't pedophile
democrats or antifa
and that people like elizabeth warren
were actually the ones who were at least
trying to do something about predatory
lending and economic exploitation
yes yes but not everyone can watch msnbc
all day
she had other priorities like fighting
overseas
and maybe since all politics is local
all she knew was that she lives in a
state that seems to care
more about her toxic whiteness than her
toxic brokenness
and that the state that's run entirely
by democrats
yeah they didn't stop anyone from
charging her 169
interest on a loan either it shouldn't
be that surprising that america is full
of fed up
unhappy people who just want to break
[ __ ]
trump sure didn't drain any swamps but
when it comes to graft and corruption
and
everybody wetting his beak california
yeah that's a swamp too
we can't put up a housing unit for the
homeless for less than 500
grand or built a rail line connecting
the state for less than 200 million
dollars a mile
even though in france with all their
socialism they did it for more like 15
million
california is a blue state that is
completely held together by red tape
it's no wonder people are leaving in
droves i am in year four
of trying to get my solar power hooked
up
just building this shed up to code
took three years we'll all be getting
our power from dilithium crystals before
my solar gets turned on
how about this will you hook it up if i
let the homeless live in it
you